women need a seat at the table and in
some cases where this isn't available
well then you know what then they need
to create their own table
well Her Royal Highness the Duchess of
Sussex hasn't just created her own table
she has invited a handful of women to it
including Michelle Obama
I remember thought my wife would be that
awesome making Markel teamed up with
British Vogue editor in chief Edward and
in full to guest edit the mags September
2019 issue the issue is typically vogue
biggest and Megan is the first to serve
as guest editor in its 103 year history
we are at a crossroads in the world
right now the decisions that we make in
every country around the world about how
we're going to treat women how we're
going to treat immigrants how we're
going to treat trans people and people
of color how we treat our planet
Megan and Edward spent the past seven
months creating what they've dubbed the
forces for change issue featuring 15
changemakers personally selected by the
duo
for the powerful and positive changes
they're making in the world I think my
force for change is me the ability to
spend time inside I
they eats the strongest force to change
the world amongst those highlighted are
Laverne Cox
Jameela Jamil Jane Fonda Salma Hayek
Yara Shahidi and even New Zealand prime
minister Jacinda our turn who the
Duchess met during her official tour of
the country last fall you'll notice
however that while 15 changemakers have
been featured on the cover there are
actually 16 boxes according to Edward
the additional box will appear as a
mirror on the printed cover and was
included at the special request of the
Duchess to show that you that all of us
in fact are part of this moment too one
person not featured on the front of the
mag shot by photographer Peter Lindbergh
is the Duchess herself in a statement
Edward revealed that the Duchess
respectfully declined feeling that it
would be in some ways a boastful thing
to do for this particular project she
wanted instead to focus on the women she
admires this includes former First Lady
Michelle Obama who talked motherhood and
maturity with the Duchess for the
magazine's Q&A feature first matters
according to Megan she landed the
interview with Michelle over a casual
lunch of chicken tacos and my ever
burgeoning bump in the rare chat the
former first lady says that motherhood
has been a masterclass of letting go
adding that it's taught her to give
daughters Malia and Sasha space to
explore and develop into the people
they're meant to be when the Duchess
asked Michelle what her 15 year old self
would think of who she's become the 55
year old mom of 2 responded that she'd
be proud but also wouldn't let her off
the hook adding quote she'd remind me
there are still too many girls on the
south side of Chicago who were being
shush cast aside or told they're
dreaming too big she'd tell me to keep
fighting for them but the best part is
what teenage Michelle would say about
Barack Obama quote if I'm being honest
she'd probably smile about how cute my
husband is too
careful what you wish for as et
previously reported the forces for
change issue will also feature
conversations between Megan and her
hubby Prince Harry as well as Jane
Goodall and stories from all 15 women
highlighted on the cover may we empower
each other to carry out such vision
because it isn't enough to simply talk
about equality one must believe in it
and it isn't enough to simply believe in
it one must work at it
let us work at it together starting now
[Music]